[Music]
news of the appearance of the fleet of
the modules of the Norseman may God
curse them from the Mediterranean of the
west coast of al-andalus in the time of
the Amir Abbott ill Ramon eben al hakam
and their attack on his people and the
great harm they did to his cities and to
the Muslims and how the Emir came to
their aid and brought reparation and
what happened during the attack insofar
as we have been able to learn for full
knowledge belongs only to God whose ways
are glorious
Ahmed even muhammad al Aziz said at the
end of the year two to nine 844 the
ships of the Norseman who were known in
al-andalus Asma Jews appeared of the
western coast of al-andalus landing at
Lisbon their first point of entry to the
Forbidden Lands it was a Wednesday the
first day of Dhu al-hijjah in that year
and they remained there thirteen days
during which time they engaged in three
battles with the Muslims next they went
on to Cadiz and after that to Medina
Sidonia the a battle took place with the
Muslims at which love even Musa was
present having received the safe conduct
from the emir about al rahman he had
received a letter from wala even Hasan
the Governor of Lisbon telling him that
along the stretch of coast 54 ships of
the magis had appeared with 54 smaller
craft and their crews and that the Amir
had immediately sent out letters to the
governors of the coastal regions so that
they might be warmed to be on their
guard on Wednesday after the 14th night
of the month of Muharram in the year 238
44 the ships of the Norseman halted at
Seville which was undefended that day
they plundered all they could taking
advantage of the negligence of its
inhabitants as soon as the news reached
the Emir Abid al rahman immediately sent
his cavalry to the river led by a bad
ally eben cool Abe Muhammad even side
even Rustom and Abad Ilhwa he'd been
Yazeed Alaskan Durrani they occupied the
AL hurry and camped there later they
were reinforced by a bird ally even
al-mundhir with a party of men who had
joined them
they sent letters to the governor's
telling them to proclaim a general call
to arms to the Muslims to fight off
these unexpected tyrants whose
unprovoked attack on a defenseless
region was without precedent people
gathered from all sides and rallied at
Cordova at their head was the eunuch Abu
Alpha nazia the favorite of the Emir
avid al Rahman who hastened out with a
great multitude and a very great show of
force
meanwhile the Norseman may God curse
them had arrived ship after ship and
occupied the city of Seville
they spent seven days there killing the
men and enslaving the women and children
until the command has arrived and clash
with them again and again causing more
and more casualties until the death toll
began to have an effect on them and it
became clear that they had been defeated
the greatest battle against them took
place on a Wednesday when there were
five nights left of the month of safar
in the year 238 44 in the village of
Tejada
near Seville
[Music]
God destroyed many of them and they died
there and 30 of their ships were burned
and many of their dead were hung from
posts and others from the trunks of the
palm trees of Seville from the day that
they entered Seville and overcame its
inhabitants to the day of their defeat
and the final departure of the survivors
was 40 days God caused their leader to
die and reduced their numbers and news
of their victory was sent to the
provinces not only in al-andalus but
also to the Berber armies of the North
African coast to a flaw in avid
al-wahhab the Lord of tahat and client
of the Umayyads and two others they were
sent the heads of the leader and his two
hundred paladins God calmed the
agitation of al-andalus which had
shuddered at such audacity against its
people and the defiance of its power and
dispelled its fear isa eben ahmed
al-razi remarking on this news said the
fleet of the Norseman may god destroy
them coming from the western sea which
is adjacent to them seized Seville at
the beginning of the year to 3844 the
first point at which they disembarked
was the island of capital some way off
the river a place dedicated to horse
breeding they disembarked on the Sunday
twelve nights after the beginning of
Muharram in the year 238 44 and their
ships were 80 in number on the second
day after their arrival four ships were
sent off to Korea Del Rio which stands
on the banks of the river to the west of
the city inhabited by Yemeni Arabs from
Yasu known as the Bhanumati four miles
from the place where they disembarked at
Cobb hill
they immediately sacked the village and
killed everyone they encountered there
in a great attack the first that they
carried out against the Muslims this
village has continued to be a rebut and
during the reign of the caliph Ovid
al-rahman third a congressional mosque
was built there because formerly it did
not have a place for prayers then on
Wednesday the third day after their
arrival the Norseman may God curse them
left the village of capital and set out
in the direction of the city of Seville
when they reached the Church of the
water
Camas at Alma to fosox from the city and
they were already closed the Muslims of
the city and others who joined them
decided to fight off the infidels they
sallied out against them filled with
great courage and determination but
without discipline they had no
designated leader not even a
standard-bearer because the governor had
deserted and fled to the city of Carmona
leaving them with no support on which
they could rely when the Norseman
approached the town from the river the
weakness of the people and their
diminishing numbers were clear to them
so they set out in their ships after
them shooting flight after flight of
arrows against them so that they
scattered then they disembarked and
fought them on the riverbanks most
vigorously and with relentless pressure
so that the civilians were put to flight
and none of them stood their ground
most of them fled back to the city each
going his own way trying to escape for
the Norseman burst upon them attacking
any who remained people who were weak or
stubborn and the wives and children of
those who fled killing seizing and
enslaving they remained in the city
seven days looting and showing no
respect for what is sacred
then when eight nights of the month of
Muharram remained they set out laden
with their booty and loaded it on their
ships they returned to their original
encampment on the island of capital
they remained for several days they
allowed the ransom of prisoners and
children but at the same time they were
enraged against the inhabitants of the
city who had fled so they returned to
the attack determined to exterminate
them the people however were prudent and
did not return nor appear at all when
the Norseman got to the city they found
not a soul there except for a small
number of fugitives who tried to defend
themselves in a mosque they were
surrounded and all were killed which
reason it became known thence forth as
the mosque of the martyrs news soon
reached the Emir Hamad Al Rahman he was
very angry and sent letters to the
districts and frontiers telling them to
mobilize their people and hastened to
come from all parts the first measures
were taken by Mohammed even Syed even
Jerusalem who set out for Seville with a
troop of horsemen who quickly reached
the district where the Norseman were
established and began to set traps for
them they set up an ambush at a place
called habla de two miles south of
Seville next to the river eben ruse tomb
sent some of his swiftest men chosen
from among the frontier guards and
others to head to the city and provoke
skirmishes with the Norseman who were
occupying it this was on a Friday when
nine nights remained of the month of
safar in the year 238 44 the Norseman
seeing that the attackers were few in
number hurled themselves against them
they moved their ships down the river in
parallel and disembarked in great
numbers to fight and pursue them until
they reached the village of Ted Java
where the commander will habit it inside
even Rooster
and the bulk of his troops lay in ambush
when the Norse men had gone past them
the Muslims sallied out against them the
Muslims who were fleeing suddenly turned
back against their pursuers who gave up
the chase dismayed at what had happened
they suffered a terrible defeat in which
God awarded their heads to the Muslims
more than a thousand barbarians were
killed and 400 captured only those who
hastened to the ships fleeing and
terrified escaped they embarked and
defended themselves from onboard
abandoning 30 ships left undefended by
their crews who were either dead or
captive even Jerusalem halted before
them ordering that the captives should
be beheaded in front of their companions
which increased their terror meanwhile
the Muslims took possession of their
empty ships and burned them all the
enemies of God shamefully defeated
withdrew thanks to God
[Music]